どうもどうもこんにちははじめ戦争で
あの世義母は100万円分買ってから
とても多くの方によ義母くださいって言わ
れました
ちょっと待ってください僕が勝ったんです
あげたい気持ちもやまやまなんですけども
俺はできればこの100万円ボンボンボン
ボンつパンスポーツ本遊戯500万円買っ
てもったいないと思うんですけどできれば
僕ちゃんと全部使いたいんですよそのため
に新教会ましたもちろんこの部屋だったら
こんな感じになってますてあのペット
埋まってるんですよ僕に何で僕最近あの
ベッドで寝てませんソファーで寝てますよ
疑問せいでこの部屋だからこうなってるん
ですきっと披露よ家だったらこの世ぎ棒等
もいい感じに使えるのではない100万円
分買ったのには理由があるんです今日動画
は100万塩分のよう希望3億円の新居に
入れたらいい感じになるんじゃないかと
いうことで
めんどくさいけど
運びます
簡易と受けて全部運ぶんですけどもこんな
密室空間にヨギ500万円分あることを
もう多分二度とないと思うんでみなさん
しっかり目に焼き付けておいてください
普通のご家庭に100万円分あると大一は
こんなことになってしまいますもうこの他
も全部雪穂もう怖いですぼくもうそこに
あるならベッドなんですよねれないんです
よいやーもう泣かないかこんな式詰まっ
てるの見れないと思うんですよねこの先
ぜひ皆さん焼き付けて下さいじゃあ
順番恋は押しでは運んでいきますじゃあ
はあああああ
ああああああああ
あっつがを見つけたすごく見つかった中に
埋もれてたんですスマホはーいじゃあん
ああああ
ああ
ああああああ
ani
ああme to me
mar
はい元の部屋に戻りましたこんな広い部屋
よりも100倍んうん感で一杯な
るってことが分かったんですけど目が
なくなると一広い
jr で全部のユニバ私がの異空間に
溜まったまで行くがに飛ばさ与儀本を今
から3億円の豪邸に長官していきます
はいというわけで新疆の一室に来ました
ラグバットも敷き詰めこの日ふさがら
100万円分の4義母があってもあのな
ジグザグ茶に敷き詰められたからなくを
受けるはずという日に早速異空間飛ばした
よ日もおいていきましょう
anwar
大2
あ
atar
はいあーん
ジッター
仁丹のカーン
ああ
ああ人さんのどちゃぶーですっ
ニャー
デイ全ての100倍いいのかわ
ええええええ護衛のスタッフのみなさんお
つかれさまでしたいやーめっちゃ大変でし
たねなんか与儀もあのモデルハウスみたい
になってますけど用の空間から脅しただけ
でまだハイツちゃんとしてないんでこんな
広いとすでにやなぜかを受けると思うんで
綺麗に輩出したいと思います
はいというわけで無事3件の新居の大きな
絵によりも100万円分綺麗においてみ
ました
whどうですかアホの半自動でもう
[音楽]
100倍おいたらこのよこれだってみて
このカラフル感すごいしか切れたらなんか
めっちゃペットみたいなやつが4つ準備
できたんですよ
anaこのペットがいつよ吟舞あります
ココとココとココとココ
宇宙これウ2て銀貨とってこの空間でも4
人いるわけですよ8つにもいい気があり
ますいやもうここを言って全部間に放題
ですからこれかわいいいやすごいですまた
100万円分買ってもこんなに余裕できる
と思ってなかったんでびっくりしてます
なんかエロイん結構余裕です実はこれ後ろ
まだ空いてるんですよ100万円分結構
めちゃくちゃ敷き詰めてもこんだけ空きが
あるっていう異常さこんな歓迎バック
ライトだけでもみんなより某デー
リラックスできますみんな東西
rar
[音楽]
ああああああ
ブーバー
し